[Musique]
elle revient elle est là pour moi
les nuits de pleine lune les câbles et
du cheveu sont en goguette chez jay lane
i maschi amis désastre est coiffeur
lunaire en coupe on masque on bronze au
clair de lune
ça s'est testé il ya deux mois et il
paraît qu'à léger mieux mais tant que
c'est derrière moi je vois pas bien je
fais confiance à de l'année au fur et à
mesure que je prenais mes car jewish
aperçu qu effectivement les croissances
de naissances se situe exactement deux
jours après la pleine lune et quelques
jours avant pas une minute à perdre
les graphes de toc et pinot gris doivent
être récoltées rapidement c'est
maintenant sous la lumière magique de la
lune que les raisins doivent exprimer au
mieux leurs qualités
c'est une matière vivante n'y a pas de
raison que le raisin soient pas
influencés par une car chaque fois qu'il
y a quitté fait référence dans un
hôpital dans un service psychiatrique
on a toujours tendance à dire là ce doit
être la pleine lune s est avéré match
crois qu'effectivement c'était la pleine
lune et il ya effectivement une
agitation l'attend dans les services
voilà j'ai regardé la lune en plein pour
fortifier les yeux ça s'appelle donc des
bains de lune est alors je regarde
pendant trente quarante comble les yeux
bien ouverts et ensuite je fermais eu un
petit moment pour me reposer et je
recommence
[Musique]